tre reporter lille est pas à mosou qui
se trouve devant les visées ville a fait
beaucoup de choses évidemment très
importante à retenir ce soir vous allez
tenter nous en résumé les quelques
grands points oui effectivement
stéphanie une allocution très attendue
du chef de l'état qui a fait beaucoup
d'annoncés qui a reconnu que cette
épidémie était la plus grave crise
sanitaire qui est connue la france
depuis un siècle
un chef de l'état emmanuel macron qui a
voulu se montrer rassurant malgré tout
qui a voulu montrer qu'il prenait les
choses en mains si l'on puis dire
il expliquait que malgré nos efforts le
virus est en train de se propager et de
s'accélérer il a donc demandé à ce que
toutes les personnes âgées de plus de 70
ans restent autant que possible à
domicile
le chef de l'état a déclaré que
l'urgence est de protéger nos
compatriotes les plus vulnérables alors
concernant les élections municipales qui
arrive dans trois jours on s'attendait
peut-être à une annonce un report de ces
élections finalement une manière de
macron a annoncé que rien ne s'opposait
à ce que les français aillent aux urnes
il a déclaré qu'il fallait assurer la
continuité de notre vie démocratique et
de nos institutions
alors parmi les autres annonces des
manuels macron le chef de l'état a
annoncé que dès lundi les crèches les
écoles les collèges les lycées et les
universités seront fermées des
fermetures qui seront valables jusqu'à
nouvel ordre
autre déclaration d' emmanuel macron
il a demandé à ce que les entreprises
permettent à leurs employés de
travailler au maximum à distance chez
eux il a annoncé que l'état prendra en
charge les salariés contraints de rester
chez eux
et puis des déclarations d' emmanuel
macron également concernant à les
frontières puisqu'il a annoncé qu'il
faudra sans doute des mesures de
contrôle et des fermetures de frontière
à prendre si nécessaire mais à l'échelle
européenne
donc beaucoup d' annonce ce soir de la
part d' emmanuel macron il faut rappeler
que le dernier comptage en france fait
état de deux mille 281 cas dont 48 décès
15 morts c'est dernières 24 heures donc
le virus se propage vraisemblablement en
france actuellement est la grande
question ce soir était de savoir si la
france est prête à affronter cette crise
si les hôpitaux français sont prêts à
affronter cette crise et emmanuel macron
à semble-t-il vouloir répondre oui à
cette question
merci la phalange en direct donc depuis
l'elysée